today we're looking at the novel of
nausea by jean-paul Sartre in addition
to my music is this quite common
multiplying used bookstores everywhere
you know this is a 1938 novel so this is
coming after start has done this his
philosophical formation but before he's
doing most of the the other work these
we can be famous for so it's very early
work if prefiguring a lot of the major
themes that are going to emerge saying
being a nothingness or at the various
plays as we're gonna see major odd he
said he's being shown up again and
existentialism is a humanism Locke took
place between the publication of nausea
and starts later worse there's the war
world war two a prisoner of war camp for
sort publication of Being and
Nothingness sort of his first really
major work
philosophy this is his first major work
of literature the occupation and then
you know starting to rebuild France
after that so this is set at a time
after World War one which radically
changed things for Europeans to be sure
but before the debacle that comes about
and it's a story of a man whose trouble
is a core that's why this is a really
great way to make it way into sort of
existentialism is a humanism it's a good
piece of philosophy to introduce sorry
this points so it's a story about this
man who like it said as trouble at his
core and is trying to make sense
something is happened it didn't happen
all at once not one single occasion
there is one primal trauma that he can
trace things to something has been
growing on him over time and he feels as
if something is out of joint you know
how at times you can almost see
something out of the corner of your eyes
or you feel as if things just aren't
right you can't live with your finger in
Canada you can't articulate precisely
what it is that's bothering it that's
what's been going on for this guy for a
while and then he starts having some
experiences and these experiences are
nausea but not although they actually
turn out terrible and he ends up telling
us you know whole story
early on in the war which by the way the
book is is there's a sort of an
authorial convention it's being depicted
as these are documents which found their
way into an editor's hands curators use
this to sort of dodge all the time
SARS is using it for this one but this
is really a young John Paul Sartre type
of guy right yeah it's being written by
or the main character who's speaking in
is on quantum of Quentin and he says the
strangest thing is that I'm not I'm not
at all inclined to consider myself with
the singing he's talking about this
experience that he and what's going on I
clearly see that I am NOT all these
changes concerned objects at least
that's what I'd like to be sure so it's
not just that something has changed
within him something has changed in the
world in experience in what he is being
confronted by and this extends to the
world of objects so it includes people
but as you notice through the border
people are treated in two very different
ways they're treated as objects that can
be described you know things that you
can sense you can see here then they're
treated as having meaning as having ten
sort of way of thinking about things
attending desires so there there's a
kind of bifurcation here between you
might say if you want to be very
Cartesian about this the body and the
soul of the mind Sartre is in my respect
Cartesian but he's not when you get down
to it the Cartesian duelist so let's
talk a little bit more about that as it
goes out of this book but first let's
think about what was this guy and what's
going on and everybody's here determine
existential crisis it's something that
we use nowadays even in sitcoms but what
is an existential crisis it is entendre
Quentin having an existential crisis is
that what this is about or is he may be
having a set of crises well this is
something worth dwelling on what is it -
Yemen existential crisis a lot of times
we talk about that as being a crisis of
meaning things made sense to us before
and perhaps you know midlife crises are
sort of in this way your role your
function changes your capacities to do
things changes you no longer and occupy
the same social space the same familial
space the same space with friends even
the same workspace and now suddenly your
identity is becoming more fluid yeah
is that what's going on with them that's
worth that's welcome how we depicted
existential crisis people don't know who
they are and have to find themselves
usually the sitcom they do so fairly
quickly if it's a movie you know takes
about five minutes
well the novel that may not happen at
all because I was doing nobody's get
those kind of endings but he's not
actually having an existential crisis
just in that sense lady says these
changes concerned objects they concern
the world as it is around him he has
he's immersed in it the natural world he
talks about you know trees the
vegetation the fringes of cities you
know the countryside but also the
humanized world cities intentionality
was just shot through at every moment
and then the other parts of the city
where you can talk for us is about a
train station having been in a certain
place and treatment sort of blossoming
around it using digital imagery where
the objects themselves started
a life of their own usually when we
neglect them
usually when we let them alone for a
while they come in to take on a
character they come to act in a certain
way but that's how it presents itself to
this character so we're seeing the world
that as a change the world actually the
world is changing at several points
we're seeing the world through his eyes
he's trying to be as attentive as we can
says himself that as his goal so first
let's think about well who is this guy
what that's that's part of the central
issue what is happening what is
happening to the world what is happening
to objects what is happening to other
people so again let's think about well
who is this guy
interestingly enough I remember when I
was a kid reading this for the first
time you know back my freshman year in
college thinking that this guy was was
middle-aged soul turns out that the
character is only thirty years old
I'm already 10 years 11 years now older
than this character who strikes me now
as being sort of a young man that's part
of what was Sartre or later on a calm
his facticity how old he is what else do
we know about him in that way
what else are characteristics of them we
know he's got red hair that comes up
several times I mean oh he's not
particularly good-looking as we can
surmise that
things that he says we know that he has
traveled around the world to many
different places if you you know lay
down the entire itinerary that would
take quite a while you could say he's
been an agent he's been Indochina China
Japan he's been all over Europe he's
been in Russia he's been to North Africa
he's been to the Middle East they spent
a lot of time there now he's in town
called Moodle what else do we know about
it well at the start if you just read a
few pages you think those two doesn't
hang around in bars and cafes but
actually he's got a project this project
is to write a book and he's been
gathering materials and doing research
thinking about these things and then
starting with you know to write and put
in the chapters and he's writing a book
on this guy the Marquita rollable so the
historical figure
he studied him previously it's all sorts
of materials gathered and he spends his
time sifting through this so he spends
his time basically at night in the cafes
and by day and oftentimes in a reading
room
doing some reading thinking working so
he's got this you know pretty ordinary
money job doing something else sweeping
more going to the box he tells us later
on is deep in the book I have no
troubles
I have money like a capitalist and a
boss and a wife and children
I exist that song and that trouble is so
vague so metaphysical that I am ashamed
so he doesn't trouble
he knows have some sort of sort of
crisis going out for set of addresses or
a malady or some sort of interior
disquiet but he says it's a metaphysical
one a lot of other people you know
they've got what we would call real
problems right maybe the person
suffering an existential crisis it's
real
oftentimes we say ah if you've had some
real problems you wouldn't worry about
all this philosophy stuff you know if
you're taking care of somebody was
terminally no or get a child was
constantly getting in trouble or even if
the child was doing great you're happy
they're not in trouble or you are
carrying on some criminal enterprise and
training with what that war you know
there's all sorts of different
possibilities here you're committed
you're in a situation you have a meaning
that overflows you then that gives you a
stable sense of who you are
although even then things can break down
and people do in fact arrive at the
place where they say I
no but the point of all this is what is
the change that takes place is it the
nausea it's not exactly the kanji we're
gonna talk about that a little bit more
later this leads us to something leads
us to a point where I want to note
something a little bit more fully that I
brought I said just a few minutes ago
that started depicts people in two
different ways he depicted suddeniy as
objects to be sensed and then described
so he talks about people's hands for
example for his own by the way is not
just objectifying other people in this
way it's also objectifying himself he
finds an unfamiliar some of his
descriptions of people they sort of
break down into all these different
sense impressions that have meaning but
not the kind of human meaning that
worries today with more sort of organic
animal vegetable mineral distinctively
human meaning or sense involves
intentions involves interpretations of
what's going on involves putting labels
on things and shoes using one's creative
acting in a determinate man of force on
some purpose with something in mind also
those who reflexive self to play
Sartre rights at all and those two
things are kind of fuse together this
work so one of the things that I'd like
to say at this point is if we look at
start just in terms of his his artistry
as a novelist as a literary figure
before we actually get into the
philosophical meet kernel that we can
draw what we can say is that when it
comes to description Sartre is
incredibly astute it hopes that he had
studied phenomenology and again we're
done with delving into philosophy here
phenomenology is a movement a style and
approach within philosophy that a
consistent large part of paying very
close attention to what is actually
being experienced by a person and then
noting that described events and try to
avoid
interjecting interpretations or
classifications
until you've actually got clear about
what it is that is being presented to
you Sark is doing a very good job with
those sorts of descriptions and as I
reread this I was just struck by how
much artistry goes into his descriptions
train stations streets the way people
move the way people hold themselves the
back of the bar the food that's put in
front of him
really amazing powers of description of
her what's going on in this in some of
these descriptions that are so
synesthetic Lee time together it means
that that information from one sense
like sight is being made sense of
through another sense say sound or touch
or pressure or anything left a lot of
those words so music it takes on a
brittleness talentless all those sorts
of things we normally do speak in those
terms that's what we call synesthesia
there's a particular kind of synesthesia
which can sort of get out of hand
Association moving from one thing to the
next
things breaking apart that you sometimes
see in psychotic discourse and search
gets very close to that at certain
points in here part of what's going on
when he has nausea when he has this
experience is things become very
unfamiliar to have things that he's used
to sensing the meaning is still flooding
him but he's having a hard time making
the sense of it being able to figure out
what's actually Frankenstein what else
is going on well from a literary
perspective another great strength of
Sartre is in presenting dialogue and
soliloquies you have a lot of different
little conversations between people and
there's there's really nothing you could
say artificial about them they're often
rather philosophical and yet they fit
they they make sense in the framework of
this novel so that's a good thing there
are also quite a few we're essentially
soliloquies where the narrator is
recounting his story is it clear who is
recounting it's who is either counting
its own offices in recounting it to
himself he's trying to you know again
they sent some of the things Sarkis was
pointing to it and inserting that sort
of thing so this is a lot of his
literature is quite good no let's shift
to start to talk more about these
characters and philosophical meaning of
this so one place to start is what we
call the problem
this courtier who requested that is
writing about who's right he is trying
to understand through this board the
attitude if you think about I'm in a
school quite a few passages from because
it's hard to make sense of literature
today doing now he's been studying him
for quite a while and he says in the
first place starting from 1801 I
understand nothing more about his
conduct it's not the lack of documents
letters fragments of memoir I seek
reports police records on the contrary
have almost too many of them what is
lacking in all this testimony is
firmness and consistency they do not
contradict each other
they contradict each other this is an
aside you could simply reject some of
them and then you don't have a set of
documents neither do they agree with
each other they do not seem to be about
the same person yet other historian the
work from the same sources of
information how do they do it in my more
scrupulous or less intelligence in any
case the question of need to be
completely cold truth what am I looking
for I don't know so he has reached a
sort of moment of crisis at least with
the respect of what he's doing right now
this guy you know thought this is
something I can do this is this is
something I am good at this is a project
I can put myself in to do look I've got
all this material I could work with I
get these kids in the bottom of this I
may not go solve the great mysteries of
the universe I may actually you know not
get married have children but at least I
can do this
well it turns out that at least when it
has to do with the essence of the human
being it's not quite so easy to do that
and you could probably say this about a
lot of other people as well if you start
getting into their stories one side well
that's kind of interesting - where did
he get these documents he tells us later
on he actually stole these documents
from the Soviet Union so this is stuff
that really matters to him for a
historian to actually steal documents
from archives that's that's important
stuff there later on as he's considering
the issue of how I can make sense of
this guy he says that the role of on
resist certainty he he makes it hard for
him to be pinned down he says I could
imagine him so well if I let myself go
no no this is doing good imagining him
beneath this brilliant irony which made
so many victims he was simple almost
naive he thinks a little but at all
times by a profound intuition he does
exactly what should be done his rescue
latias pianted spontaneous generous as
sincere as his love of virtue and when
he betrays his benefactors and friends
who turns back from regular to the
events of drawers over the world he
never thought hey this lady's right over
others anymore than
there's over because this is a very
attractive character isn't it
he says but if this is where it all
needs me I mean better off writing a
novel not walk none of that not a piece
of history not something that purports
to actually tell who this person was but
make the person a fictional character in
a novel eventually he gets himself on
the point where he has to be in his
project writing and unreliable he says
those new categories winters is as
crisis how can I have not the strength
to hold to my own past hope to save the
past of somebody else he starts to
realize that what he's been doing and we
all do this you know anyone who's a
historian packs a philosophical figure
we all do this in a way we're all trying
to sort of bring that to life something
which has passed away he's talking again
still about trying to write and he says
as my eyes fell mechanical white sheets
I was struck last look at a state pen or
a study that stands that the paper so
hardened by us seeing some present the
letters I had just inspried minute were
not even drying it and already they
belong to the past so I'm trying to
write about this person who's long past
and the past that he lived in in the
present woman's that keep on slipping
away into the past and when I'm done if
I had a book that would just be a sort
of a consolation of past moments this
strikes me was being kind of funeral if
you can't find meaning there it's at
this point actually he says that the
true nature the present revealed itself
we're going to come back to that and and
he he ends up saying to himself continue
this process the student roll the bone
was my hurt he needed me in order to
exist that I needed him so as not to
feel my existence so checking out this
this project was laid for Quentin to not
feel his existence to not be troubled by
his existence to avoid dealing
the crisis so now that's what's actually
looking at these these crisis and then
we'll look at some characters of how
they have a difference what we know
about the Bellagio
well I mean insert never actually like
spots for a moment says okay here's
exactly what I mean by the Gaggia now it
happened again here and it happened
again here in happened here but here's
the essence of it it's that what he does
is he that he tells us about its go over
points he tells us times when he has at
times when he doesn't have it and we
have to kind of put the picture together
in a competent way so let's actually
look at some of the occasions where
where this this occurs early on in the
book he says things are bad things are
very bad but I haven't the filth the
nausea and this time it is newt is
coffee in a cafe up until this point
he's been suffering it but not in cafes
not in places where people are gathering
it says till now cafes reminder refuge
then the nausea seized me I dropped to a
seat night no longer knew where I was I
saw the colors spin slowly around me I
wanted to vomit and since that time that
nausea has not left me cold that's a
description of what's happened what does
the nausea as you like well he says he's
coming to actually have sex with the
Cafe and the waitress says she's not
here she's shopping that says they felt
the sharp disappointment in the sexual
parts along disagreeable tickling okay
understandable right at the same time I
felt my shirt rubbing against my breast
that was surrounded seized by a slow
colored mr. worldwide spin the smoke and
the beers and the booths glowing at the
back of the cafe and I couldn't see why
it was there or why that was like that
so this is not just a thing that's
occurring within his his body you know
feeling nauseous feeling like he's
better off being sick it has to do with
a sense perception has to do with his
grasp on the world that's actually
making him feel sick things come unglued
things flow as having longer describes
these these sorts of effects he's
talking about this guy adult he's
watching animated says his blue kontrick
stands up directly against a tropical
wall that to brings on the nausea here's
where he says something very interesting
that no one see is not inside me I feel
it out there in the wall in the
suspenders everywhere around me it makes
itself one with a cafe I am the one who
is it yet so again this is not just a
being sick and it's not just stimulus
response this is coming through in the
very way in which he is perceiving the
world the nausea is out there to be
perceived by him in the world it's it's
not something that's a purely subjective
reaction on his part instead this is a
revelation for Sartre unmediated reality
let's look at another discussion paid
later on he talks about the nausea going
away why does it go winces no I just
stay down there and be happy this cold
is so pure this nights will cure him I
myself not a wave of icy air either one
or Linden or flesh to be nothing the
coldest so one thing that keeps the
nausea at bay is very simple almost
mineral they'll say they are on mineral
like abstract we a little bit later on
here or a little bit before that sorry
he he loses the dogs get as well
terribly
why well he misses to a record a jazz
record which is being played at the cafe
and he says what has just happened is
that the nausea has disappeared where
the voice was heard the silence I felt
like honey hardened and the nausea
vanish suddenly it was almost unbearable
to become so hard so brilliant
he's not talking about you know his
sexual arousal or anything like that
he's talking about something more like
having definite contours things like
everything having its place and things
being almost written in the way in which
they they stand out against each other
so from everything sliding into
everything else losing its
sort of outlines and consistency to
moments where everything is totally
clear but almost kind of static those
are the two poles that he goes between
you a little bit later on he talks about
something which is like the master but
that one of the themes is good then
we're going to get out as soon as we
eventually it says nothing has changed
and yet everything is different I can't
describe it it's like the noise you know
again it's just the opposite so there is
a state which is like the know as you go
but is not the goddess yeah and is in a
certain way not necessarily like it's
polar opposite but it certainly changes
the world around him and it's meeting at
last an adventure he happens to be and
when I question myself I see that I am
myself and I am Here I am the one who
splits the night I am as happy as a
beautiful phrase I am as happy as the
hero of a novel to say something is
going to be happen something is waiting
for the shadow of the yeah I think
writing about things we can really
relate to and just like the nausea which
is out there in the world and it's not
just like I said a matter of stimulus
coming to us and then we have a
subjective response but rather our
perception of what it is out there this
is another way or see
the world the world is opening itself up
and things are there for me and I am
there for it and something is going to
happen that's what it's part of the
essence of adventure he says sometimes
thing is waiting for me at the end of
the + du couteau
there is also the plastic Katonah that
at the end of the room to read something
which needs me in order to come to life
I am full of anguish the slightest
movement hurts me I can't imagine what
they want with me let's choose it turns
out to be something fairly attributable
and says but this is a this is something
that gives us a good contrast over the
hospital later on he runs into another
character who says he has the NAS we're
gonna look at him a little bit further
this is very interesting he says I don't
know Ozzy habits of people he could
actually happen to the world he talks
about kids like that he says he's talked
about what happens
a roomful of bookshelves today they
fixed nothing at all it seemed that
their very existence was subject to
doubt watch out they're the greatest
difficulty passing from one it's into
the back say how the book I was reading
tightly in my hands but the most violent
substations went dead nothing seemed
true I felt surrounded by cardboard
scenery which would quickly be removed
the world was waiting holding his breath
making itself small it was waiting for
its convulsion its with nausea
just like the seer I kill the other day
so it's not just people that can suffer
this sort of shifting this here in
essence fixed meaning started gelatin
and flow away and things transmuting
into each other
unpredictably the world itself can be
concerned
later on he asks himself is he having
the nausea he an interesting lady he
says an immense sickness flooded over me
suddenly of the pen fell for my hands
love's fluttering what happened did I
have the nausea no it wasn't that the
room had its maternal every day look so
he's not having that this sort of sense
disorder the table hardly seemed heavier
or solid to me nor my
pack only atmosphere to roll along and
died for the second time after he has
made sort of metaphysical realization
about things he was in question actually
readable the further he was still there
inside me a little while a little quiet
and warm and I could feel it stir from
time to time he was quite alive getting
down with the heavens ability to say
several things without showing himself I
mysteriously find and I can whether a
prophet he put his nose down and I could
see his pale face with butchie's nothing
more was left now no one's more than on
these traces of drying has left a memory
of their freshness suddenly noiseless
Marquita rollable had returned to his
nothingness
so you can have these these sort of
experiences without all of the world
shifted and also that sort of physical
sickness because he has another fountain
that namazi Anna the strongest yet this
time revealing the nature of existence
to him well he has at once with the self
Walkman and he leaves and he goes into
eventually to the park and in that party
comes to an understanding of month of
nausea actually yes so this is a good
place
this says this moment was extraordinary
I was there motionless of icy plunge
into a funny - a horrible ecstasy with
something fresh and just appeared at the
very heart of this ecstasy I had
understood the nausea
I possess to tell the truth that did not
formulate my discoveries to us but I
think it would be easy for me to put
them into words now the essential thing
is contingency I mean that one cannot
define existence as necessity to exist
as simply to be there those who love
themselves exist who exist love
themselves being comfortable you can
never deduce anything from so along with
the effective
sensory experience the nozzle goes a
metaphysical insight into the existence
of things the nature of things
these permeate each other these are two
sides of the same coin this is a good
place now before we actually try to look
at that directly to look at a few of the
characters in this novel the science but
to see some of the relationships so by
far the one who gets the most space is
and you know if wrenches Auto deduct the
auto dynamically the person who is
talking so we're going to look at in a
moment
who else matters who else or sort of
pivotal points where you might say
almost like lighthouses by which we can
we can turn our which there's a solvent
man there's another character the Corsa
people I'm not going to talk about get
some complex with some and then there is
Monsieur and there there's a broad
category of there we go
where do I see words a lot of characters
and that's representative of them the
one who we're going to focus on here is
dr. J then there's another character
who's very important as well and but I
don't want to put her up here quite now
I want to wrap up by looking at her
because something different is going out
of there so there's a lot of other
characters involved in this there's you
know people at the bars cafes some of
them actually
you know little crises their own
pointing at one time who runs into two
of them north of me and it looks like it
to be leaving the woman tearfully but I
don't want to focus on that I will focus
on these three in part because they have
to do with what the novel is really
about what so they actually before we
get to the South time and let's look at
the interplay between word well first of
all let's look at the boardwalk there's
three main parts where Sark really
deposits and he's you know the sort of
traditional thing for French literary
figures unless they're actually
defending the word Watson to attack
affordable for all sorts of things we do
that to an hour but they represent
something in particular for and you
talked about them on Sunday that he goes
out into town on this particular Road he
talks about them in terms of the gallery
museum and then he also talks about this
dr. Roche so let's look at what happens
then at that Sunday he goes out and I'm
just gonna read a few short passages
right he is
yeah
Rouge Joseph penciler and all these
these these people are coming out on
Sunday and they're engaged in this
process
this dance almost social niceties
they're engaged with each other they're
tipping their hats to each other they're
walking there's certain protocol for all
of these these things that are engaging
as well somewhat Hoffman [ __ ]
patron and protege interaction and all
sorts of different things as well and
Sartre was not particularly fond of us
but he does depict it very well and he
shows all these people that played on
Sunday engaged in these things that they
think matter and that's really the
harder the boardwalk for wrong by
thinking that the things that they
encounter in their world are the way
things must be that they have a definite
essences and things are the way that
they should be in this case it's sort of
sets up its own kind of micro universe
its own social universe in which they
have the right to be and they have the
right to the exactly as they are
same thing comes up as well when he is
talking this very long passage about the
museum and I just want probably someone
character in this museum
rubbing character there are all these
different pictures there you know in all
these different pictures these these
well I'm going to read you a little bit
of one of them portraiture is supposed
to show the essence of the person right
so this portrait painter did a good job
and confidence in there he's looking at
one of these that he says his judgment
went through me like a sort of
questioned by every right to exist and
it was true
I had always realized I am
right to exist I had appeared by chance
by existed like a stone on a planetary
micro but for this handsome faultless
man now dead for Jean Cocteau
it had been an entirely different manner
the beating of his heart the new
rumbling of his organs in his case
assumed the form of rights to be
instantly obeyed for 60 years without a
halt he had used his right to live the
slightest I would never cross those
magnificent gray eyes Coleman never made
a mistake he always done his duty all
his duty is duty as a son husband father
leader he never weakened in his demands
for his due
so weight hindering the borderline
universe are these people who have a
sort of mechanism of social life that
they're committed to they feel very
confident about it helps to keep all the
uncertainties all of the worries all of
the anxiety that they can't picture that
actually having served us if they did
well then you lock them up in an asylum
even if they have strange ideas well
that's where this other guy comes at
Remmy
why does he walk why did he have his
prestige he was loved because he
understood everything you could tell him
anything
socialists well I go further than they
do when you followed him down this
perilous road he resumed to leave behind
not without a shiver family country
private property rights and the most
sacred values you even doubted for a
second that right of the bourgeois elite
to come in another step and suddenly
everything was reestablished
miraculously fundaments all the reason
good old reasons
you turned Romney saw the Socialists
already far behind you all waiting all
tiny waving their handkerchiefs as shot
at wait for us
so ribbon Carol terminus is a philosophy
recession he takes you know young men
who are having their own little crises
and he breaks everything down sort of
like a dick hurt right and then he
builds it all back at once all the
reasons they happen to be the reasons of
the borders it all makes sense doesn't
work for her sergeant for a repentant
let's look at dr. Rocha dr. Rocha comes
into a bar
we're sorry I remember once in his had a
contact with Miss Reiko yeah he comes in
he's sort of larger than life and here's
how I almost start to surprise he's a
professional and experienced doctors for
priests magistrates and army officers no
man is ruined through Sathya
and he calls mr. Keogh
Allu sort of dismissing the judges
categorizes Sarco is not to describe
them some mortises they would like to
make us believe that the past is not
lost that their memories are condensed
gently transform into wisdom convenient
cast past handed out of the pocket
little bill books full of light sayings
believe me I'm telling you from
experience all I know I've learned from
life they explained the new by the old
and the old they explained by the rule
they're still like those historians in
terms of Lenin into a Russian hopes here
Aloha spirit adventure promenade when
all is said and done they've never
understood anything at all so dr. Rocha
is the type of person to come in and
categorize and he's drawing up a
prestige that comes about because he's a
a great man of the world he's been
successful and he's built up all this
this experience what start is finding to
fault with him for is for taking the
dead past and projecting its categories
on to the present so it makes the world
in which he lives almost like sort of a
mausoleum or
a museum full of you know in Canada
China freeze dried specimens and it
causes other people tend to choose
whether they're going to participate in
this or gonna so this gets us to
Monsieur Akhil Monsieur IKEA is actually
somebody who is having something similar
to what our economist
he says the little man stirs and sighs
here he is looking at
this time he's going to speak to me and
I feel all hot that's right there's no
sympathy to us we are alike that's all
he is alone as I am but more sunken into
solitude tonight he must be waiting for
his own nausea or something of that sort
dr. Rocha comes in and then he sort of
jokingly says mr. Hill you let people
like that in here and then he says he's
crazy as a loon that's that what he
happens well this year our killer has to
make a decision and he decides one
random horse our offences with all the
witnesses there it is the man smiles
with humility a crazy loon he relaxes he
feels protected against himself nothing
will happen to him once was born I am
reassured to crazy old lumens so that
was it that was all the sea Rock Hill is
probably happier than he has ever been
he is a gate with admiration the doctor
knew how to take it the doctor wasn't
one to let himself be hypnotized by a
madman on the verge of the habitats fit
one would blow a few Rock lashing words
that's what they need Sartre says I am
ashamed it was your ex you we are on the
same side we should have stood up
against them I guess
but it's hard to do that isn't it I mean
this is this is the sort of thing that's
experienced where it is you know there
is a commonality there but it's not the
kind of commonality that draws people
together it's not as if existentialists
could have police sergeant
existentialists agreed enough solidarity
he says we're on the same side which
should have stood up against him but he
left me he went over to there's Keith
honestly believes of experience out in
his not mine dr. gachet's a little while
ago mr. Hill felt queer or lonely now he
knows there are others like him many
others dr. Boucher hasn't met them he
could tell this year killed the case
history each one of them and tell how
they ended up
thus your Achilles simply hates and he
lets himself be brought that easily to
the accepted ideas however I like to
tell it how I would like to tell me is
being saved is the blood of an important
experience professionals they dragged
out their life in stupor and semi-sweet
they lived at granite and essentially
what about the Auto deduct the soft this
character gets developed a lot more
depth
what is his project well he actually is
in the reading room and he's trying to
appease the self-education is trying to
read through everything in alphabetical
order and he ever so often writes down
so it's a maxim that catches his eye and
he has the feeling that if he just keeps
at it
he's been eventually exhaust the realm
of knowledge there and it'll finally be
educated you'll finally be ready and
this is a very strange way of doing
things isn't it but this is what he's up
to and you can tell the kind of attitude
that he has towards things by this this
really interesting encounter that he has
with Quentin where he says I just trust
myself so much I want you to read it
everything and then after that it's not
a book of it's not true
later on
he expresses itself and he asks if
that's in any book that book wanted his
revenue said I don't think so and they
said wow that must be wrong if it's not
on the board
if it was true somebody else would have
figured it out that would have written
it down and would be in a book it's not
a book he's doubting us he's doubting
his own capacity to bring about
something new or something interesting
something worthwhile at the same time
one of those it wasn't motivated he has
a secret desire to have something that
he calls adventures they go they will
get photographs together and what does
he want to do after education he says
when I finished my instruction I had a
lot of six more years that I shall join
if I permitted the group of students and
professors who take an annual cruise to
the nearest I should like to make some
new acquaintances speak frankly
innovation also liked it so that
something unexpected they happen to me
something new adventures what sort of
adventures I asked of astonished all
sorts was here getting out of the rocket
train stopping an unknown city losing
your briefcase being arrested by mistake
spending the night in prison the seer I
believe the word adventure could be
defined at an event out of the ordinary
without being necessarily extraordinary
people speak of the magic of adventures
does this expression seem correct - I
would like to ask you a question this
year if you had many adventures and this
is a very important point because we're
Quentin will actually reflect on things
and he'll still end up staying to this
view I have had many adventures what he
will end up saying later I've never
actually navigate ventures remember
though the nausea itself the state that
was similar to was a state
feels like he's on the verge of having
an adventure so this is notion of
adventure the self-made man will Quentin
to have that income that's something
that motivates them that's something
that is common to their way of
understanding time we're going to get to
that a little bit more on a second
installment when we look at the
Quentin's own sense right now we're just
exploring the real crux that occurs
between them it's not actually at the
end of the salt SWAT man turns out is
also he gets caught by the course of
course it was Ben watch out for
something the self-taught man is trying
to top squeeze these boys who sort of
daring each other to go screw with that
discreetly but where's desire is very
clear and it gets kicked out that's not
the real culmination that's sort of the
anticlimax the really important thing
that happens between these two guys is a
launch that takes place the self-taught
man invites reflectin to lunch and she
wants to communicate something damn now
these are these are just people out on
the street these are people who have
been saying reading room for about a
while they've shared a few few
confidences they share the same space
and same time at these but there are
interpretations of it are very different
this is a occasion an incident with it
that's very important for for science
philosophy and so you can see more
Quentin by contrast the go-ahead way to
be on appeal so he says what happens
first is the South time and they're
sitting there and looking around the
room and Quentin says what a comedy all
those people sitting there with a
serious meeting no they aren't meeting
there's the recuperating in order to
successfully finish their tasks each of
them he has its little personal
difficult
keeps him from noticing that exists
there isn't one of them who disbelieve
himself indispensable to something or
some each one of them does one small
thing and no one is better qualified
than he to do it no one's better
qualified than the commercial traveller
over there to sell Swan toothpaste
no one is better qualified than that
interesting young man with his hand
under his girlfriend's skirts and I am
among them and if they look at me they
must stick that no one is better
qualified than I to do what I'm doing
but I know I don't look like much but I
knew I existed that they exist if I knew
how to convince people have go sit down
next to that handsome wait here
gentlemen
explain to him just what existence means
these peepers don't laughing them so the
soft one says laughing about I was just
thinking but here we set all of us
eating and drinking to preserve our
precious existence and really there's
nothing nothing absolutely no reason to
exist so itself talk man become serious
he makes an effort to understand me and
laughter well if you repeat slowly no
reason to exist you undoubtedly mean in
this year that life is without goal
isn't that what one might call esta
Muslim he thinks for a moment and then
it says gently a few years ago I read a
book by an American author it was called
just life worth living is another
question you're asking yourself and it
says to absolve certainly not that is
not the question I'm asking myself
to explain I'm going to Portugal I think
we've all had this experience having
something that we're thinking out and
feeling it out at the same time it's not
just cognitive it's also effective and
you don't fully have our heads wrapped
around it maybe because it's too complex
or because it touches on deep
metaphysical roots or because we haven't
lingered with it long enough we haven't
we haven't unpacked all of them we
looked at it from all different sides
that you need to and somebody wants to
call us on the spot saying penny for
your thoughts and we're supposed to tell
them what's on our mind you know we've
all had the experience of any sort of
trivialities of human exchange when
we're trying to grapple with something
and it doesn't necessarily have to be
massive you know surgery and existential
crisis it can be you know when you are
grieving somebody comes up to you and
you know grief is in this street as well
you're grieving and they want to talk to
you about stuff and you're willing to
talk with them because you're not a
juror but you you can't communicate you
can't get across what it is that's on
your mind and they may actually want to
know what's on your mind and then they
make guesses that and they say things
here and there anyway that's not it
that's what's going on this past so he
says the salt Watkins says his
conclusion is in favor of voluntary
optimism light has a meaning if we
choose to give it one one must first act
throw oneself into some
if one reflects that dies already cast
what is pledged I don't know what you
think about that was here requesting
says not what's going on in his head is
it says rather I think this precisely
this sort of line at the commercial
traveller the two young people the man
right here telling us that if you just
find something to do to care about to be
preoccupied with now you're like this
meaning this is gonna make philosophical
position this is what when some people
have in fact advocate it's not just you
know optimist and self-help therapists
to these things there are there actual
philosophers out there advocated that
sort of approach to life is a healthy
approach to life now something that
doesn't bother says neither's neither is
it my opinion I do not think we need to
look so far another direction I should
take there is a good there is a rule
there is humanity and then start so
that's right forget he was a humanist he
remain silent long enough to make the
most of the spiced beef and slice of
bread and disappear clean here
there are people he has just painted the
whole picture of himself man services
yes but he doesn't know quite how to
express myself
he sees a crew of University says naive
and barbaric provincial humanist right
Sartre says you don't seem particularly
cool Quentin says you don't seem
particularly concerned for people you're
always alone homage of you knows in the
courses Wow
let's hear you're wrong allow me to tell
you what in the air I've been waiting
for the opportunity to tell you this he
says and then you know there's a bit of
back and forth complements going on and
he talks about this experience that he
had to area variable in a prisoner of
war camp they were all herded into this
gigantic barn and they do they're all
crammed in there together and he felt
suddenly sort of animal love after one
with everybody else around him and then
that changed so he says after that the
year of my liberation spent many
miserable months I didn't know what to
do with myself I was wasting away
whenever I saw a man to gather evidence
certain I saw another group but I found
my vocation what is it with this
vocation he's a socialist
I've been a member of the Socialist
Party says the month of September 1921
that is what I wanted to tell you though
this is deep dark secret and now why
busiest socialist says I don't feel it
alone by being a socialist now
what certain ends up talking about here
is humanism and what he sees as its kind
of traps its deficits it's its
inadequacies
so this is this man the self-talk is
ineffective human says what can I do
isn't it my fault if in all he tells me
I recognize the lack of the genuine
article is with my qualitative as it
speaks i see all the humanists I have
known rise up I have known so many of
them the radical humanist
one the radical humanist is the
particular friend of officials the
so-called left humanist being worried is
keeping unit values he belongs to no
party because he does not want to betray
the human but his sympathies go towards
the humble he consecrates his beautiful
classic culture to the humble he has
generally had a bitter war with a finite
always clogged with right sentimentality
coma
always you know the downtrodden and
Sarge was actually saying here there's
something a little hinky with that the
communist writer has been loving men
since the second time here clay supposed
to he punishes because he loves modest
is all strong men he knows how to hide
his feelings but he also knows
look an inflection of his voice how to
recognize behind his rough-and-ready
juju juice tichel utterances his passion
for the Brethren so we've got no radical
leftist humanist
sentimentalist essentially the
Communists of the realm
these are not just these are not
communists in state these are companies
who actually have a chance of getting
power the communism was devoted to do
some sort of humanists ideas it was
benefiting humanity the Catholic
Buddhists the late member of the
Benjamin speaks of men with a marvelous
hair what a beautiful fairy tale says he
is the humble wife of London Doc Hanna
the girl in the shoe factory she has
chosen the humanism of the engines he
writes with their ratification long sad
and beautiful novels which frequently
when the priest Eminem those are the
principles so radical Yunus communist
Catholic but there are others with swarm
of others the humanist philosopher who
bends over his brothers like a wise
elder brother who is a sense of his
responsibilities the humanist who loves
men as they are the humanist who loves
men as they ought to be the one who
wants to save them but their consent
will see in them in spite of themselves
the one who wants to create new myths
and the one who satisfied at the old
ones the one of the most death and man
the one who loves lengthening the happy
humanist
always does the right word to make
people like that the silver humanists
who you meet especially at funerals are
waste they all hate each other he says
as individuals naturally not as men
because of course you know as men as
human beings are all supposed to love
each other but what they love is some
sort of abstract conception of what
humanity is not genuine human beings who
don't don't actually know who the hell
they're and are all mixed up you know
this is you know Chara swirled about a
circuit board but you know light and
darkness mixed all in together and a lot
of times are inexplicable to themselves
the self-taught man doesn't know he's
locked them all up inside himself like
cats in a bag and they're tearing and
tearing each other in pieces without his
noticing it the education of the
self-made man has has providing
themselves largely a humanistic
education and he's trying to mix
together all these figures all of whom
who do express some sort of love for
human beings or our data duration or
respect or care pick whatever you like
but do so in different layers and can't
tell you about real living present human
life is about servicing so you saw on
this event the Venice and now there's
another important movement that takes
place
yes sir twice rather yes
I'm not sure I haven't and the self-made
man like he says he asks little for me
simply to accept a little piece of
trying things I was trying to fit star
into the classification system that he's
developed it is a trap if I can set the
self-taught man wins
I am immediately turned around
reconstituted overtaken for humanism
takes possession and bounced all human
attitudes into one if you pose him how
to play his game
give this off his opponents there's a
race of beings limited and headstrong
who lose to him every time he digests
that all the violence is of course
successes he makes so many other people
allow themselves to be categorized by
them because they don't know but to
truly exist for sharks as a human being
means to refuse others attempts to
categorize you and to refuse your own
temptation to buy into those
categorizations he says I don't want to
be integrated I will not be fool enough
to call myself an to your business why
not well if you define yourself as just
anti something where you define yourself
as the good guy against the bad guy
you're still defining us you're still
imposing these categories then they have
this discussion about heat and starts
character or cleanses who do you mean
actually one who who are you fooling
I mean you know a lot of people are out
here look at this cafe what can you tell
me about those people if you actually
love them you'd actually know something
much distance you see you don't love
them you wouldn't recognize them in the
street there are only symbols in your
eyes you're not at all touchable
you're touched by the youth of man the
love of man of one of the human voice
well doesn't that exist a self-taught
man says and again you know very bookish
and certain the spouse is anomalous
category system no those things don't
exist what exists it's this this and
this and that person over there that
person over there there's no such thing
as the love of man or any of these sorts
of things on their own
it doesn't exist neither youth with our
maturity or old age nor death
so service is going out to get scat here
and what ends up happening is he leaves
they their encounter is over